what is economics
or maybe
what is or should be the goal of
economics well it should be i understand
how human civilization comes about and
how it can be maintained
uh and that's not what it's been at all
so we have a discipline which has the
right name and the wrong soul
what is the soul of economics the soul
of economics
really is to explain how do we manage to
build a civilization that elevates us so
far
above the energy and
consumption
and
knowledge levels
of the base environment of the earth
because if you think about and this is
actually working from
work i've learned from tim garrett who's
one of my research colleagues as an
atmospheric physicist and his idea is
that we have these we exploit these
high-grade energy sources from the sun
itself to coal nuclear et cetera et
cetera which means we can maintain a
level of human civilization well above
what we'd have if we're just still
running around with rocks and stones and
spears
so
it's that elevation above the base level
of the planet which is human
civilization and if we didn't have this
energy we were exploiting if we didn't
use the environment to elevate ourselves
above what's possible in the background
then you and i wouldn't be talking into
microphones
you know yeah we might be doing drum
beats and stuff like this but we
wouldn't be having the sort of
conversation we have so it explained how
they came about that what's the
economics should be doing and it's not
so this is the greatest thing that the
earth has ever created is what you're
saying this conversation yeah we're the
most elaborate yeah construction on the
planet and like that's not what we've
done we've denigrated the planet itself
we don't have respect for the fact that
life itself is an incredible creation
and i
i my ultimate
if i had to see how humanity is going to
survive what we're putting ourselves
through then it would we'd have to come
out of it as a species which sees its
role as preserving and respecting life
i like how you took my silly incredible
statement and made it into a uh
a serious one about
how amazing life is life is incredible
and when humans don't respect it enough
we trash it
and
and that's what economics i think has
played a huge role in that so i actually
regard my discipline i would never call
it a profession let alone a science uh
my discipline has probably helped bring
about the termination
potential the feasible termination of
human civilization strong words okay
let's return to the basics
of economics so what is
the soul and the practice of economics
what what should what should be the goal
of it because
you're speaking very poetically but
we'll also speak pragmatically
about the the tools of economics the
variables of economics the metrics the
goals the models
practically speaking
what are the goals of economics well
then in terms of the tools we use we
should be using the tools that engineers
use frankly and that's which sounds
ridiculously simple because you would
expect that economists are using
up-to-date techniques that are common in
other sciences where you're
dealing with similar ideas of stocks and
flows and interactions between the
environment and a system and so on and
that's fundamentally systems engineering
and that's what we should be using as
the tools of economics now if you look
at what economists actually do
the sophisticated stuff involves
difference equations
and like difference equations you know
if you've done enough mathematics as you
have you know difference equations
are useful for like individual level
processes if you're talking about a
autonomous on it'll go from state t to t
plus one t plus two and so on but not
when you're talking at the aggregate
level there you use differential
equations to measure it all
economists have been using difference
equations so there's like a book i think
it's by sergeant and one other are
called advanced methods in economics
using python two volume set
it's about close to two thousand pages
and four of those pages are on
differential equations
the rest is all difference equations so
they're using entirely the wrong
mathematics to start with for people
listening what is difference equations
versus differential okay a difference
equation is is like you can do in a
spreadsheet you'll have this is without
even 1990 this is the value for 1991 92
and 93 94. so you have you have discrete
jumps in time
whereas the differential equation says
there's a process moving through time
and you will have a rate of change of
the of a
variable is a function of the state of
itself and other variables and rates of
change of those variables and that is
what you use when you're doing an
aggregate model so if you're modeling
water for example or fluid dynamics you
have a set of differential equations
describing the entire body of fluid
moving through time you don't try to
model the discrete motion of each
molecule of h2o
so at the aggregate level you use
differential equations for processes
that occur through time
and that's economics it occurs through
time you should be using that particular
technology but
some economists do learn differential
equations but they don't learn stability
analysis so they simply assume
equilibrium is stable and they work in
equilibrium terms all the time and
that's uh it is the the the technical
level it's an incredibly complicated
uh way of modeling the world using
entirely the wrong tools okay we'll
we'll talk about that because it's
unclear
what the right tools are yeah maybe it's
more clear to you but i've got to make
it clear to an audience well
so this is a very complicated world it's
a complex world you talk about their
uh some of the most complex
systems on earth are the human mind
the economy and the biosphere yep so
we'll we'll we'll go you know i'm we'll
go to that place i'm uh fascinated by
complex systems i'm humbled
by them even at their simplest level of
like cellular automata
i'm not sure what the right tools are to
understand that especially when part
part of the complex system is like a
hierarchy of other complex systems so
you said the economy is a fascinating
complex system but it's made up of
human minds
and those are interesting those are
those are interesting perhaps impossible
to model but we can try and we can try
to figure out how to approximate them
and maybe that's the challenge of
economics
you